Element 110 is darmstadtium and darmstadtium
is named
after the German town of Darmstadt which is
where the big
German accelerator, the so-called Gesellschaft
fur
Schwerionenforschung, the Society for Heavy
Iron Research is
situated and this is because darmstadtium
does not occur
naturally and has to be made. So as element
110 you have to
have the nucleus of the atom actually having
the right
number of protons to be 110. So it is 110
protons, so the
way that they do it is that they take a lump
of lead, I have no
idea how big and fire at it at enormous speed,
ions from
nickel. Lead is element number 82, nickel
is element number
28. 28 plus 82 adds up to 110. So the idea
is that these
nickel atoms bang away all the time, at the
lead and most of
the time, everything flies to pieces but one
collision every
hundred or thousand million, the two nuclei
can fuse together
and for a short time form the element. And
so element 110
was formed in this way and only a few atoms
have ever been
observed.
The nucleus of the atom is electrically charged
and so they
have an accelerator which contains negatively-charged
plates
which accelerates these things up close to
the speed of light,
so there are enormously energetic. It is like
propelling a
cricket ball at fantastic speeds so they have
a huge amount of
energy because if you imagine it the two nuclei
are both
positively-charged; you need an awful lot
of energy to get
these two to go together. It is like banging
together two
magnets which have the same polarity, you
can’t really push
them together easily they tend to repel, but
if you push them
hard enough - boom!